[Musique]
on a un burger maison qui s'appelle le
burger donc avec le pain qui ont
fait nous-mêmes sa part en livraison les
deux de commandes différentes
enfin moi perso je reste ouvert c'est
vraiment pour garder le lien le lien
avec mes clients
habituellement donc c'est toujours mes
clients qui viennent chez moi c'est moi
qui s'est maquillée qui vais arriver à
leur domicile ou à sur leur lieu de
travail
on sent bien que c'est dur pour tout le
monde et tout
vous pouvez vous aider
[Musique]
je les regarde pas trop ces chiffres
parce que sinon c'est un peu le bourdon
décontracté mais j'y touche pas c'est
bien beau de mettre en place des prêts
mais il faudra les rembourser ces prêts
vous voyez c'est un peu le chien qui se
mord la queue
7500 euros pour un établissement comme
le nôtre on a entre 18 et 20 mille euros
de charges mensuelles
[Musique]
je passais de rester actif
ouais si on
notre collègue qui suit aussi qui parle
de son de tambours notre envie de
sortie j'avais envie de faire ce verset
t'en fout les boules
voyez contrairement aux chaises qui sont
vides l'état vides à la limite que je me
dis bon ça reviendra quoi là là on parle
quand même on pas quand même deux ans
déjà que j'aime avec qui j'ai plaisir à
travailler à partager plein de choses et
là on joue là on touche à la santé
vraiment ont tout faux moral à la santé
des gens